DON'T GIVE A BLEEP ABOUT ALL
THEIR SANCTIONS.
HERE NOW SENIOR FOREIGN POLICY
ADVISER OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION KRISTIN WHITEN.
ALL RIGHT, SO IS THIS AN
INVASION?
IS THIS WHAT THIS IS THE
PEACE-KEEPING FORCES.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
PEACE KEEPING.
IT'S NOT REALLY AN INVASION --
IT AN INVASION IT JUST HAPPENED
IN 2014 SMALL PART OF EASTERN
UKRAINE INVADEDs 2014 LITTLE
GREEN MAN RUSSIAN ARMY TROOPS
TAKEN OFF INSIGNIA NOW THEY ARE
MAKING IT FORMAL.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT.
IT'S A COSTUME CHANGE AND
REBRANDED AT PEACE KEEPING
TROOPS.
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
DOESN'T CONSIDER THIS A NEW
DEVELOPMENT?
THEY ARE GOING TO WAIT MAYBE
HAVE A MEETING OR TWO.
SCRATCH THEIR CHINS AND PERHAPS
SLAP SOME SANCTION ONCE TOMORROW
MORNING?
>> YEAH.
THE MESSAGING HAS BEEN SO WEIRD
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN SO STARK, SO
UNCONDITIONED, YOU KNOW, BIDEN
DECIDING PUTIN HAS MADE THE
DECISION TO INVADE BECAUSE OF
OUR INTELLIGENCE, WHICH
CERTAINLY HAS NEVER BEEN WRONG
IN THE PAST.
AND SO TO SAY THAT THIS IS
COMING AND NOW WHEN, YOU KNOW,
PUTIN ACTUALLY DOES MAKE A MOVE
THAT DEALS WITH SOMETHING ACROSS
THE BORDER, NOT IN RUSSIA
PROPER.
YOU KNOW, BIDEN EARLIER SAID
THAT, WELL, THERE MIGHT BE MINOR
INCURSION, IT WOULD BE NO BIG
DEAL IT JUST GOES TO THE SORT OF
INPRECISION, CLUELESSNESS BIDEN
HAS BEEN THROUGH ALL ALONG.
INCIDENTALLY NEVER HAS HE
EXPLAINED WHAT U.S. INTERESTS
ARE REALLY ON THE LINE HERE.
>> Jesse: HE HAS IT AND HE HAS
NOT PREPARED THE COUNTRY FOR
WHAT'S AT STAKE IN TERMS OF
ENERGY PRICES.
I MEAN, WE ARE GOING TO GET
HAMMERED.
THAT'S GOING TO MAKE INFLATION
WORSE.
HE HASN'T TOLD US WHAT THAT'S
ALL ABOUT.
AND WE'RE WAITING,
MR. PRESIDENT.
EXPLAIN IT CHRISTIAN, THANK YOU